the nfl buzzing about last sunday
night's classic between the chiefs and
raiders the silver and black felt
they let a win get away but john treach
is here to tell us
more about what they're learning from
this loss as they now prepare for
a game against the falcons john that's
right the raiders are thankful to be six
and four but not exactly sending a plate
of yams and casserole
to patrick mahomes the mvp chiefs qb can
go ahead and sit at the kids table we
don't have room here
on sunday night the raiders had a
three-point lead with a minute 40 left
in the game patrick mahomes and the
chiefs proceeded to carve them up for
a 75-yard game-winning feast it hurt but
the raiders can't dwell on defeat and
must spend their turkey time thinking
about another formidable bird
the falcons and i always tell them you
got you got to win you got to take
lessons whether you win or lose a game
especially when you lose so sometimes
when you win you feel good and and and a
little detail here there
uh we got to stay on top of it but uh
the guys are in good spirits they're
excited to go this week
i'd say they're more pissed than
anything it's just a correction that we
came in on monday we fixed
i mean the one thing we that i learned
from it is you know you can do your job
the entire game that one play you don't
do your job
it shows up and you know it just
happened to show up at a critical moment
in the game
you know it was a division game you know
one that we definitely wanted you know
coming off of
you know a tough week you know and you
know it's the kansas city chiefs you
know that's one we all wanted you know
one we can't get back you know we just
look forward
you know we just have to go out there
this weekend each and every week you
know moving forward to make sure we do
our part
that way we get a chance to face those
guys again you know that's all we can
hope for
that is all you could hope for the
raiders are surly which works out well
they need to stay away from people and
stay coveted concern free because
right now in week 12 of the nfl season
the best ability
is availability